once upon a time Tom Holland was best
known for starring in the stage version
of Billy Elliot in the 2012 disaster
flick the impossible
of course that all changed when the
British actor appeared in Captain
America's Civil War donning the iconic
spider-man suit to fight against Steve
Rogers what's up everybody
Marvel fans everywhere thought Holland
absolutely killed it as Peter Parker and
they also agreed
he looked ripped as everybody's favorite
web slinger he might have even made some
of his co-stars jealous for how
well-liked he was in the flick but how
did he physically transform from a
scrawny tot into one of the world's most
famous superheroes here's everything you
need to know about how Tom Holland
turned himself into spider-man shaking
it into shape unlike a certain actor
who's best known for playing star-lord
Tom Holland was in great shape long
before landing the role of spider-man he
started out taking hip-hop dance lessons
in England as a kid and went on to study
ballet for two years in hopes of landing
the title role in Billy Elliot in
addition to helping him get bigger
Holland's dance background has really
aided him as an actor he told interview
magazine I'm very happy I had that
training it's been so valuable to my
career and I've used it on almost
everything I've done since that
experience certainly came into good use
when he cross-dressed for lip sync
battle with exactly zero fear of losing
any dude cred hitting the mess every
avenger has his or her particular skill
set Iron Man flies in blast off Black
Widow does martial arts
spider-man climbs walls does flips and
makes Olympic gold medalists look like
old men of course Peter Parker got his
acrobatic skills courtesy of a
radioactive spider bite Tom Holland on
the other hand gained his gymnastic
abilities from years of hard work
dedication and risking his neck like his
dancing history he credits his stage
work on Billy Elliot with his earliest
exposure to gymnastics they trained me
in gymnastics while I was doing that
show and it's just something I kept up
while finishing the show and for my
auditions for spider-man Holland is also
into freerunning a form of parkour that
emphasizes creative expression in other
words it involves a lot of
chromatics not to mention some semi
dangerous stunts speaking with Metro
Hollen once explained me and my mates go
free running all the time
I've probably jumped four meters on the
grass and two meters between buildings
in addition to keeping a Magi land
limber which is essential if you're
going to play the wall-crawler himself
Holland's gymnastic abilities might have
helped him land the role of spider-man
in the first place during the audition
process he transformed what would have
been a run-of-the-mill screen test into
an eye-catching exercise of his flipping
skills and I basically did like a summer
so into frame and then a summer saw out
of frame I need them to know that I've
got some gymnastics abilities and stuff
considering Tom Holland is the guy
currently wearing the Spidey suit it
looks like his acrobatic skills paid off
changing things up another training
technique Tom Holland has adopted to
swell up to spider-man size his circuit
training this controversial exercise
involves wearing an elevation mask while
performing multiple sets of reps like
burpees or bicep curling one after
another with almost no rest in between
stations and that's not the only
experimental exercise he's tried he's
also given electronic muscle stimulation
a whirl along the way - and they put
pads on you and you work out while the
pads electrocute you and it's it sucks
it really really sucked and while he had
some trouble with it at first I tell you
I did it once and I didn't go to the
toilet for two days he's since given it
another go hopefully with less troubling
consequences punching it out if you want
to be an Avenger sooner or later you're
going to have to throw down with some
bad guys
luckily Holland is big into combat
sports not only is he an MMA fan showing
up at UFC events he also spends quite a
bit of time in the gym learning all he
can about the sweet science as a result
Pollan totally knows what he's doing
when he pulls on a pair of gloves
when he's not punishing those punching
bags Holland also does every other gym
activity imaginable including chin-ups
side lateral raises and even borrowing
Thor's hammer to beat on some massive
tires so perhaps one of the most
effective elements of his workout regime
is how consistently he hits the gym
while still mixing up his routines
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]